Verfolgt das Cityscape!
so ob der Kram alles funktioniert
er muss da nicht eingepläntet werden ein stream ja relativ früh 14 30
so früh monka x monka s monka x monka giga monka mega monka s
ja schön dass so viele schon da sind was ist denn hier los warum seid ihr denn schon alle da
nach normale leute müssen arbeiten um die uhrzeit ich ja eigentlich auch aber bei mir hat sich das
ja montags erledigt home office lul sehr gut ja man kann es ja fast schon als fortbuchung
veranschlagen ja urlaub auf viel viel gut man ja ja komm ich krieg schon weniger kohle da kann
ich wenigstens auch mal so tun als ist es das einzig wahre dass wir vier tage aber die woche
aber ich bin auch überzeugt von dass das das beste was man machen kann du kannst das auch machen
die kriegt in der schweiz eh so viel geld easy übrigens ich muss mal kurz refreshen
mein twitch zeigt außer dem chat nichts an keine zuschauer keine vorschau kein sonst
irgendwas was sagt vorlesung gammeln exzellent ein easy as fuck sagt die
aber ich verstehe man kann das man kann das falsch verstehen das japanische text to speech
ist halt noch verbesserungswürdig aber ich meine man versteht es verhältnismäßig gut
kommen wir jetzt zum beispiel zum beispiel wo habe ich denn jetzt ok das ist wieder übelst
mies abgemischt kann sich wieder nicht entscheiden welche lautstärke was haben soll
exzellent so also ja flix coda mein fall ist es auch nicht aber ich trinke kaum was
das einzige was ich trinke ist ab und zu mal zu weihnachten irgendwelche wein irgendwelche
weine oder was auch ganz leises ist whisky aber ich trinke eigentlich so gut wie nix
trinke nur exquisite sachen exzellent habt ihr schon windows 10 windows 10 20 h2 installiert
ich habe es ja noch nicht na also guckt von mir ist noch 2004
übrigens mal linux starten weil wir brauchen jetzt auf jeden fall linux vm gibt es was
besonderes neues nein du kannst jetzt das startmenü also das einzige was mir hängen
geblieben ist an neugigkeiten ist dass jetzt im startmenü der blaue der blaue hintergrund
hinter icons weg ist das ist das einzige was ich mir gemerkt habe was neu ist anwende
aus 2010 zwar nein 20 h2 das ist das einzige neue was ich mir gemerkt habe ich meine dafür
kann man auch schon mal ein halbes jahr brauchen ich meine hier diese sachen wegzumachen ist
schon mal ist schon mal ein halbes jahr arbeit kann ich kann ich nach vor allem für die
greilen hacker bei microsoft ist das so also erstmal die ganze kreml hier weg machen haben
wir es wieder ausgeschaltet docke docke rps alles weg sehr gut also es gibt seit ungefähr
einer woche gibt es jetzt vmw sx für respire pie das ist so ein ding wo leute seit jahren
danach gefragt haben und was das gefragt muss ich auch leute o o leute ich hab grad was
ganz ganz kritisches gesehen ich hab meine kamera nicht nicht beschwert das heißt wenn
die runter fällt dann wird geleakt monka leak das risiko wollen wir nicht eingehen deswegen
muss die kamera beschweren also das ist ja mein iphone von dem ich das streame ja es
gibt ja schon andere virtualisierungsmöglichkeiten was man auf respire pie machen kann also man
kann jetzt mal anfangen mit kleinen sachen was zwar keine richtige virtualisierung ist
irgendwelche lxc lxd docker geschichten dann kann man weitermachen mit kvm dann gibt es
jetzt xen seit neuestem auch von respire pie das ist die die zitrix geschichte oder citrix
oder citrix oder zytrix citrix ich weiß gar nicht wie man das richtig wie spricht man
das richtig aus ich weiß ja nicht mal wie man richtig schreibt so oder wie spricht man
das aus wie aussprache citrix citrix wie spricht man das besonders cool aus ok ok wie
spricht man das aus how to pronounce citrix ok ok das müssen wir uns jetzt mal anhören
wir machen das die coolen leute emma saying das ist wieder so ein video 5 sekunden 5 sekunden
ein wort gesagt und erstmal 30.000 intro 33 33 sekunden intro moment die machen ernsthaft
ein video ist das jetzt ein mensch oder ist das text to speech ist ein mensch oder ist
das ein mensch das ist schwer zu sagen das können auch text to speech sein
ja wie oft wiederholen die das jetzt weep text to speech das machen wir jetzt mal da
crash aber wieder wenn ich das das ist nämlich das hat nämlich den bug und ich war bisher
zu faul das zu fixen wenn man text to speech hinzufügen will und ich glaube man muss das
man muss das erste mal hier umstellen und jetzt und jetzt geht das citrix ok das hat
mit der realität überhaupt nichts zu tun ich verstehe nichts ich verstehe absolut gar
nichts ok wichtig gut gut dass wir das jetzt mal angehört haben
wie man das nicht ausspricht gut jetzt macht die eigentliche sache was ich gerade sagen
wollte nochmal fertig fertig also es gibt ja wie gesagt paar sachen von respiratory pie
was virtualisierung angeht kvm oder wie gesagt docker gedulds was keine wirkliche virtualisierung
ist aber das ist ja recht beliebt um respiratory pie dann kann man kvm machen dann kann man
neuerdings xen machen also diese zetrix ne zetrix systems kann man machen und jetzt
neuerdings kann man auch vor allem esx machen das ist eine sache wo seit jahren schon danach
gefragt wird wenn ihr mal sucht hier reddit esx pie da gibt es reds von 2006 oder 2007
oder so und und das wollen sie alle haben so und da kam es immer als antwort lohnt sich
doch überhaupt nicht gibt es eine alternative zu vmw converter kein schimmer ich kenne mich
mit vmw nicht wirklich gut aus so und da kam als antwort immer ich verfolge ja so ein bisschen
auch so die ganzen reddits subreddits von sachen die ich nicht unbedingt jetzt jeden
tag jeden tag verwende so die standard antwort ist immer darauf so nachdem warum will man
sowas machen ja genau sowas wie der chillfreak fragt und ich finde das ist eine berechtigte
frage weil mir fällt auch nichts dazu ein was man wirklich großartig damit machen will
aber das ist wahrscheinlich genauso wie warum will man ein kubernetes gedöns laufen lassen
auf seine raspberry pie erstens weil es geht und zweitens weil man dabei was lernt ich
glaube den raspberry pie ist eine super übungs mg umgebung wo man sich das ganze daheim angucken
kann ohne dass man da jetzt größere investitionen tätigen muss ja man kann sich man kann sich
glaube ich mittlerweile esx auch nestet virtualisiert machen auf dem firma workstation ob das geht
auch ja kussi was ist mg monka es was möchtest du uns mitteilen also ich glaube das am ehesten
ist noch dass man das eben lernt damit dazu kommt ja auch dass das nicht nur ein bild
von raspberry pie ist man kann es auch auf anderen armen sachen installieren aber ganz
viele leute wie gesagt wenn man verfolgt haben sich das seit jahren gewünscht so die sache
ist die ich habe kein ich habe kein acht gigabyte esx kein acht gigabyte pie ich habe nur vier
gigabyte pie vier das war damals der größte den es gibt aber die sagen man brauchen dann
vier oder acht gigabyte model also probieren probieren aus was ich nicht so ganz mit verstehe
was die uns hier sagen wollen was data center near edge und fahre edge ist das ist bestimmt
vor mwr speak den man als normalsterblicher nicht versteht außer man ist vor mwr certified
architekt oder irgendwie so gedöns was auch immer nie edge und fahre edge sein soll oder
data sender kannst du mir wenigstens noch was vorstellen stonkskiller aber ja hört sich
echt so an so jetzt müssen wir die ganze kram erstmal downloaden ich habe noch nichts
gemacht normalerweise ist ja so dass ich hier im stream öfters mal zumindest sachen mache
wo ich im vorfeld schon ein bisschen geguckt habe wie es geht nichts ich habe gar nichts
gut ich habe keinen plastenschimmer wie das funktioniert so wir downloaden das jetzt
erste mal hast du momentan oder habe ich nicht ich habe anfangen ende november habe ich
urlaub dann also in vier wochen oder so habe ich habe ich heute habe ich dann wieder urlaub
so download geht nicht weil man sich einen account machen muss deswegen machen wir uns
jetzt erstmal in den fake account don't have to sign up now excellent machen wir dann machen
wir uns mal hier 10 minute mail account ob der da exzellent die perfekte die email adresse
genau die brauche ich email email passport alles klar das ist was was jetzt oh nee alter
vor allem ich habe doch ich habe ok ok groß und klein schreibung dann machen wir es so
muss ich mir wieder ein passport ausdenken was diesen kack passportrichtlinien entspricht
was eh kein mensch braucht ok also jetzt groß und klein schreibung gut so tell us
tell us about yourself cute chat cell phone null wir sind ein individuell address poggers
street 69 wenn schon wenn schon dann richtig beknackt city frankfurt am ein die checken
bestimmt nur 6 0 3 2 9 ist das select one in germany referred language englisch warum
man das ausfüllen muss keine ahnung das das füllt eh keiner richtig aus for ever usernamen
omega null nein nein ich will ich will mir bleibt doch eh nix anderes übrig wie es zu
sagen ok ich agree alles alles agreed capture enter capture ok kb 6 v 5 sign up easy noch
mal captures 8 h m never da ist es doch activate your account activate now das war ja einfach
das war ja um nicht zu sagen erst mal schön fake erst mal schön fake account anlegen enter
your password to complete ok noch mal diesen ganzen müll eingeben wahrscheinlich brauchen
wir das dann danach eh nie wieder crimson one was machst du auch es nix ausprobieren
oder wie oder was ne oder wahrscheinlich was anderes so also jetzt können wir das
ganze kram runterleihen was braucht man dafür wie gesagt ich habe keinen plan von for ever
ich habe zwar schon mal installiert wir hatten übrigens mal ein der hat sich bei uns als
linux system engineer frag mich nicht was das genau war cloud services keine ahnung
beworben und er hat geschrieben er hat erfahrungen mit ubuntu er hat fortgeschrittene linux erfahrungen
und ubuntu und da haben wir den gefragt ok was haben sie da schon gemacht und da hat
er allen ernst das ist jetzt kein witz ich hab ich denke mir das nicht aus manchmal denke
ich mir schwachsinn aus aber das habe ich mir nicht ausgedacht da hatte gesagt er hat
in dem erst ich schon mal ubuntu installiert das war die window das war fortgeschrittene
linux erfahrung easy also wenn das schon fortgeschrittene linux erfahrung ist da weiß
ich auch nicht ok was braucht man denn hier alles von es ist ein vorab iso das brauchen
wir mal wohl ne yes yes yes yes wir agreeen wir agreeen zu allem zu allem moment warum
ah ne ich muss mir das unter linux runterladen ich muss mir das gar nicht hier runterladen
was mache ich denn was mache ich denn für Dinge ich muss mir das hier ok erstmal den
ganzen ganzen shit hier wieder zumachen vom letzten mal oh zu viel zugemacht so zack moment
wie heißt meine email adresse noch mal aha hier alles klar und jetzt muss ich noch mal
das passwort eingeben kontrol w beste man kann auch alternativ einfach alles schließen
machen oder nachdem ich jetzt in den browser aus versehen zugemacht habe hätte ich auch
mal den browser schließen kann oh ne erstmal gleich gebannt da gibt es ne anleitung ja
die werde ich mir auch gleich runterladen also was brauchen wir denn das da brauchen
wir auf jeden fall das brauchen wir auf jeden fall vmw vmw moment ich bin verwirrt ne das
brauchen wir nicht oder brauchen wir das doch äh genau es gibt nämlich ne anleitung das
habe ich auch gesehen die gab es hier ja ja auch gut ja rück hier die seite brauchen wir
da gibt es nämlich den ganzen kram zum download ok das haben wir schon zum accept ja ja wir
accepten alles ok dann kommt man hier raus alles klar gut das brauchen wir nicht save
das passwort doch für die zukunft ich brauch das net so und dann haben wir hier nen pdf
äh firefox wow alter was ist denn was ist denn mit euch los what the fuck ok wahrscheinlich
ist das wieder so ne typische vmw anleitung jeglichen sonderfall abgefackelt in wirklichkeit
muss man dreimal klicken und es funktioniert also require info bla bla bla bla bla bla
use case is far edge a virtualized iot gateway ah far edge alles klar zum glück nicht microsoft
edge cringe joke so was gibt es als nächstes required and supported hardware good power
supply das haben wir ich hab das offizielle was ist das 3 ampere äh 5 volt nix netzteil
ich sehe da wirds kam gut an im chat hab ich hab ich hab ich ein sd für uefi firmware
usb drive for iso installer usb drive moment ich brauch nen usb stick und ich brauch nen
usb ja das ist ja gut hab ich ja alles wozu willst du die sx auf rest of your pine szene
weil es geht weil ich gucken will ob es geht und was man dann damit machen kann ich glaube
nicht dass es nen sinnvollen anwendungsfall dafür gibt den man wirklich äh quasi betreiben
will wo es mit was anderem nicht auch geht also es ist ne super umgebung glaub ich um
zu üben ein bisschen zum beispiel ist für mich zum beispiel ist ne gute sache ich hab
ja keinen plan von vmw so also das passt alles das haben wir alles ihr seht ja ich hab mehr
oder weniger alles da also hier mal gucken ähm ich hab alles da ich hab nen usb stick
da ich hab ne 2 sd karten da ne micro sd karten micro sd karten 128 g ähm micro sb micro
sd karten reader ist alles da also passt euer nemes ist 216 weil es muss doch korrekt sein
underscore 2 underscore 1 underscore 6 pains champ ja ok also power supply gut power supply
bla bla bla haben wir alles jetzt kommt mal zum punkt der geek pie ok das ist so ne typische
vmw anleitung wo wirklich gott und die welt und jeder noch so kleinste furz den man lassen
kann irgendwie drin steht brauche alles net usb device brauche alles alles vollkommen
egal ja hab ich hab ich gemacht passt ist aktuell hab ich ich hab ich hab erst gestern
oder so auf dem raspberry wir können den noch mal ich mach noch mal ein update leute
schade ich mach noch mal ein update ist ja nicht verkehrt ich mache mal kurz
das macht
Okay, ja, also das machen wir mal, ich mach noch mal ein Update, das schadet ja nix,
wenn wir mal ein Update machen. So, mal gucken, wer da gebootet hat, plinke, plinke. Das Ding
müsste die gleiche IP haben, wie wo wir letztens meinen Home Assistant ausprobieren, 11, 140.
Aber da bin ich ja nicht mehr per SSH drauf, 140. Endmap, SSH, doch, excellent. Wahrscheinlich
ist er nicht gebootet, ne, er bootet noch vor sich hin. Müssen wir kurz warten, bis er gebootet
ist, dann mach ich nämlich noch mal ein Update. Ach, da ist er. Update, ich mach noch mal ein Update.
Man weiß ja nie, man weiß ja nie. Und dann fangen wir an. Jetzt seht ihr, seit einer Woche,
seit einer Woche ist das raus, das ist ganz, ganz fresh ist das. Wobei fresh sagt man ja
heute nicht mehr. Heute, also korrigiert mich, wenn ich falsch liege, wenn man heute, wenn man
heute irgendwie was zustimmt. Also, ich bin ja mit 36 jetzt nicht mehr ganz so aktuell,
was Jugendsprache angeht. Genau, einmal, es gibt Sachen, die sind wild, wild, wild. Aber
wenn man zustimmt, dann sagt man auch, was will der denn? Was war das denn jetzt? Upgrade. Ja,
wenn man zustimmt, dann sagt man, ich fühl's. Hab ich so, hab ich so das Gefühl, dass man sagt,
dass man das dann sagt. Das fühl ich, sagt man dann, das fühl ich. Ist das so? Fühl ich,
ja ich. Digga, genau, fühl ich digga. Ähm, gibt nichts zum updaten. Was, was genau wollte
der mir eigentlich hier mit seinem Colonel-Update-Geschiss sagen? Gut, ist mir eigentlich wurscht,
braucht man nicht. Das fühl ich ist noch älter als fresh, nee, das fühl ich, das ist jetzt grad
neu. Lost, Lost gibt's auch noch, genau. Ja, ich bin da nicht so ganz auf dem aktuellen Stand.
Ist das noch vom 64bit Colonel gewesen? Kann sein. Ist aber auch wurscht, er hat alles geupgraded,
passt. Ähm, ich glaub wir können anfangen. So, also, was, was müssen wir denn jetzt machen?
Plug in SD-Card into Pi and Power. Was zum? Sicher? Das muss man doch wahrscheinlich gar
nicht mehr machen. Das muss man doch wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr machen. Ist das nicht normalerweise
diese Sache, wo die sogar empfehlen, dass man es nicht macht? Was passiert da, wenn man das macht?
Achso, ja. Äh, was auch immer, wir sind moderne, wir sind neuer als das, was die da drauf haben,
alles gut. Ich find's ja toll, dass die bei, von Vmware Screenshots mit ihrem Handy machen vom
Terminal. Da gibt's keine, da gibt's keine, da werden keine ordentlichen, da werden keine
Screenshots gemacht und da werden auch keine Capture Cards verwendet, da wird mit dem Handy
abfotografiert. Die haben gar Geld bei Vmware, das muss man verstehen. Aber Vmware ist ja hat
ja auch, ist ja auch keine, keine, äh, kein YouTube Influencer, sondern Vmware machen ja
auch ordentliche Sachen. Die dürfen, die dürfen auch abfotografiert. Oh, hohoh, Bildqualität,
exzellent. Shutdown Pi, ok, jetzt, jetzt geht's eigentlich los. Gut, das hätten wir uns jetzt
auch sparen können. Gut, so, also. Download necessary Bits. Download Latest Official Raspberry
Pi Firma. Was machen die da für ultra kompliziertes Zeug? Das braucht doch kein Mensch. What the fuck?
Ok, die Anleitung ist ultra vir, Alter. On Windows, nee, nee, nee, wir machen das nicht
on Windows. Prepare, wenn, wenn die Anleitung mir zu dumm wird, dann guck ich, ob das auf
YouTube schon mal einer installiert hat, ich mach das einfach nach. Also, Prepare SD Card,
Format SD Card with Single FAT32 Partition. Dazu brauchen wir doch kein Windows, da haben
wir mal Gparted auf. Äh, Moment, erstmal muss ich, Moment, erstmal muss ich die Micro
SD Card rein decken. What? Warum registriert sich das unter Windows, das soll sich gefälligt
hier registrieren. Connect, yes, exellent. So, sudo Gparted, warum, warum soll man das
unter Windows machen? Ich weiß nicht, was, was mit VMWare los ist. Gerade VMWare will,
dass man die Sache unter Windows vorbereitet. Dazu fällt mir bloß ein. Das ist wirklich,
ich weiß nicht mehr, wer es gemacht hat, aber das ist Big Brain Emote hier. So, alles weg
da, alles, alles weg. Delete. Kann ich das nicht deleteen? Ah, nee. Moment. Ah nee, ich
hätte fast meine Festplatte gelöscht. Puh. Ich hätte fast meine Festplatte gelöscht,
anstatt den USB Stick, äh, anstatt die Micro SD Card. Ich, Tommy sagt, was, ich raste aus,
mein Prof antwort mir jetzt kurz vor dem Bewerbungsgespräch am Mittwoch, ob ich noch Interesse an einer
Stelle hätte. Ist doch gut, da kannst du dir beides angucken. Sag ihm, du hast Bewerbungsgespräch
und, ähm, da kannst du dir beides angucken, ist doch nicht verkehrt. He doesn't know,
he lacks critical information. Okay, ähm, ich mein, sag dem ruhig, sag dem doch, ja,
du hast Interesse, du kannst ihm doch sagen, ich hab jetzt am Mittwoch oder so ein Vorstellungsgespräch,
aber was hat er denn? Also, ich mein, schade doch nichts, sich das immer alles anzugucken.
So, erst mal alles weg hier, alles weg. Delete, delete, accept, delete, bam. So, ähm, okay,
was, FAT32 brauchen wir, gut, FAT32, alles klar. Wenn die FAT32 haben wollen, machen wir FAT32 hier,
FAT, wo ist hier FAT32, bam, komplett alles FAT32. Exzellent. Jetzt haben wir 100, äh,
100, 120, ich wusste gar nicht, dass FAT32 so viel kann. Nee, warte mal, war FAT32 nicht
bis maximal vier Gigabyte Dateigröße? War da nicht was? Ja, doch, ne? Captain Peng sagt,
auf meinem Laptop läuft im Moment PopOS und dank Linux erkennt meine Lüfter nicht. Hä,
seit wann muss Linux Lüfter erkennen? Also, es ist eher der umgedrehte Fall, wenn du mit
Linux Sensors das erkennen lässt, dann kannst du sie leiser machen oder steuern,
aber standardmäßig sollten die eigentlich ordentlich kühlen. So, was hat er hier für Schmerzen?
Keine Ahnung. So, weg. Refresh. Exzellent. Zack, quitt. So, gucken wir mal, ob wir das
Ganze mounten können. Mount, def, ups, mount, def, SD, B, eins nach MNT. So, und zeigt
dem jetzt auch an, das ist ein schönes, nee, BLKID war das. Moment, VFAT? Hab ich VFAT genommen
oder FAT32? VFAT ist eigentlich was anderes, ne? Ich hab FAT32 genommen. Ich guck noch mal
nach. Nee, hab ich, passt. Okay. Äh, Moment, vielleicht soll ich ihm noch sagen, dass man
das mounten kann, dass er es booten kann, hä? Das machen wir noch. Noch boot, bootflag. Wo
setzt man hier Flags? Checks? Manage Flags? Boot. Wir setzen nochmal bootflag. Das ist
bei so oldschool Sachen nicht verkehrt. Warum kann ich das nicht applyen? Wurscht. Okay,
also mounten wir den ganzen Krempel. Mount. Zack. So, und was müssen wir jetzt machen?
Also, on Windows brauchen wir das Ganze schon mal gar nicht machen. Okay, open up Windows.
Ähm, okay, das haben wir gemacht. Was wird hier, wir installieren ESX auf dem Raspberry
Pi. Das gibt seit einer Woche eine Beta-Version. Extract Firmware Master ZIP and delete all
files starting with kernel image. Okay, ich muss wirklich diesen Mist runterladen. Das
da muss ich runterladen? Was, was ist das? Das hab ich noch nie, okay, ich lad das andere
auch noch mal runter. Das hab ich noch nie gebraucht. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das
existiert. Okay, also jetzt muss ich Firmware Master ZIP extrahieren. Das geht ja schon gut
los. Okay, download. Jetzt schon kein Bock mehr auf die Installation, ja. Moin, wie weit
bist du mit der Installation? Wir haben noch, wir bereiten grad den USB Stick und das Zeug
vor dafür. So, hallo, the download nicht, fertig. Doch, also unzip Firmware Master. Wow, da alles
drauf. So, und was soll ich jetzt machen? Extract Firmware Master and delete all files
starting with kernel image. Firmware Master Boot. Man kann die Leute aber auch echt das
Leben schwer machen, oder? Was ist das für eine Installation schon wieder? Also was,
ich soll alles löschen mit kernel. Okay, machen wir alles kernel, mitgelöscht. Exzellent.
Sonst haben wir hier nichts mehr mit kernel drinstehen. Okay, wunderbar. Ja, das ist ja
gut, dass da der fixup4db.dat dabei ist. Da ist ganz schön viel fix, hier fix, fixup4x,
fixupxd, fixupcd, dass da alles gefixt wird. So, haben wir gemacht. And copy entire boot
directory onto newly formatted SD card. Das machen wir mal alles gut. Home, max, download,
Firmware Master, boot. Muss übrigens cp-r machen, weil ansonsten kopier das nicht.
So, da haben wir es. Wollen wir den Inhalt oder muss man boot kopieren? Okay, nein, man
soll das ganze verzeichnend auf die SD-Karte kopieren. Okay, haben wir gemacht. Weil es
hätte ja auch sein können, dass man den Inhalt von boot direkt auf das root von der
SD-Karte, aber ich glaube, die wollen, dass man den Ordner kopiert. So, und jetzt brauchen
wir extract exquisite high quality images hier bei Firmware. Ah, yes. Also, ich glaube,
die Datei ist ganz besonders wichtig hier unten. Also, es gibt, also es ist nicht so,
dass das Stream grad encoding Probleme hätte oder so. Das erkennt man wirklich nicht.
Trimolon, null. Trimolon sagt, aber krass, dass Firmware noch Master benutzt. GitHub
hat das ja geändert. Ja, stimmt. Also, mal ganz ehrlich, warum benutzt Firmware Master?
Das finde ich, das finde ich ja highly offensive. Könnten Sie das nicht Main oder Staging oder
anders nennen? Master geht ja mal gar nicht hier. Anzeige ist raus. Also, was muss ich
jetzt machen? Und schon gar nicht, wenn die Chinesen das machen. Was muss ich jetzt machen?
Extract Raspberry Pi UEFI Firmware ZIP and copy all files with them direct into the same
boot directory. Okay, das ist natürlich ein äußerst super hilfreicher Screenshot. Das
bringt mir ganz, ganz, ganz viel, dass ich jetzt erkenne. Okay, also das heißt, ich soll
jetzt zurückgehen. Ich soll anzip machen auf UEFI. Wie heißt das? Anzip auf UEFI Firmware.
Oh nee, hatte das jetzt. Ich hasse, wenn diese Dinger so kacke eingepackt sind. Jetzt hat
er das nicht in extra Ordner entpackt, sondern direkt in das Download verzeichnet. Ja, ganz
toll. Okay, MK dir. Schieben wir es halt nochmal. Und anzippen das nochmal hier. So, also was?
Ich soll jetzt alles von hier. Alles von hier in das. In das Boot Verzeichnis hier kopieren.
Habe ich das richtig? Also chat, wenn ich jetzt irgendwas verkehrt verstanden habe, sag mir
Bescheid. Also, so wie ich das jetzt verstanden habe, ich soll alles von hier. Okay, das eine
löschen wir mal hier. Ich soll alles von hier. Na, da kopieren. Mach's doch lieber über
Windows. Warum? Das macht's doch auch nicht, dass es da abkommt. Über absolut keinen Unterschied,
ob ich das jetzt unter Windows mache, die Anleitung oder hier. So, habe ich gemacht.
Alles hinkopiert. Also da ist dann. Jaja, genau hier und da. Alles, alles hinkopiert.
So, und was macht man jetzt? 4GB Pi only. Edit. Konfig TXT. Und was? GPU Memg gleich
16. Ach, das ist das mehr. Also. Das ist, dass ich mehr RAM frei habe für ESX. GPU
Memg gleich 16. Okay. Eject SD-Card and put SD-Card into Raspberry Pi. Ach, gibt's auch
eine Linux-Anleitung? Hätte ich vielleicht mal weiter scrollen sollen. U-Mount. Okay,
wir scrollen erstmal weiter, was jetzt noch kommt. Das ist die Mac-Anleitung. Ja, das
haben wir schon alles gemacht unter Linux. Nur, dass es hier jetzt noch mal zeigen, wie
es auf dem Mac geht. Okay. Design on your console choice. HDMI plus USB. Ja. Exakt,
so machen wir das. HDMI und USB Keyboard machen wir. Oh, da brauche ich meine Capture-Card
gleich. Wiring. Okay, das ist egal. Das brauchen wir alles nicht. Was für eine Anleitung,
Alter? Ach, man kann das auch über einen Terminal installieren. Okay, das ist gar nicht so blöd,
aber um Raspberry Pi kann man ja einfach was anschließen, was gut ist. Skip zu. Zu was
soll ich skippen? Skip zu. Skip zu. 3, 3, 4 soll ich skippen, ne? Ja. UEFI Configuration.
You can use HDMI USB Keyboard. Power to Raspberry Pi and then keep mashing escape key when
prompted. Okay. Ich war noch nie im BIOS vom Raspberry Pi. Oder was auch immer das jetzt
genau ist in die UEFI Shell. Boah, ist das kompliziert, der Installer. Okay, das heißt,
ich muss jetzt erstmal meine Capture-Card anschließen. Okay, Capture-Card. Warum gibt es dafür nicht
einfach ein Image? Das ist der Filter von VMWare. Nur Big Brain Leute sind erlaubt,
ESXi auf dem Raspberry Pi zu installieren. Das bedeutet, man muss den Installer kompliziert
machen. So, ich schließe meine Capture-Card an.
Kabel. Einzelne USB-Kabel, was ich habe.
Snapchat.
Also, das heißt jetzt müssen wir wirklich auf den Raspberry Pi ins Pios, das habe ich
noch nie gemacht.
KennyTV sagt, du hast mit Programmieren und so nichts am Hut, aber das findest du, das
ist doch nice, wenn dir das gefällt.
Ich finde das auch immer schön, wenn Leute, die jetzt vielleicht nicht ganz nach irgendwelche
Technik Sachen machen, trotzdem da einfach was abgewinnen können.
So, auf geht's!
Elgato!
Elgato, mal vor dich hin, mach mal!
Achso, der Raspberry Pi ist ja aus, keck weh.
Ähm, okay, das heißt, ich muss jetzt die Tastatur umstöpfen.
Meine Güte, das ist ja richtig Turnschuhe-Abinstallation hier, du musst ja permanent hin und her laufen.
Jetzt muss ich die Tastatur anschließen noch am Raspberry Pi, okay, mach ich, mach ich,
mach ich, mach' ich, mach' ich, mach' ich, mach' ich, mach' ich, mach' ich, mach' ich,
jetzt muss ich escape hemmen, escape, camera escape, wir haben gesagt es soll escape drücken
ah ich bin ja blöd bis also also
ich habe ich habe es falsch gemacht leute erstens ich habe die sd karte nicht eingelegt
und zweitens ich habe noch die alte ssd dran die booted das kann ja gar nicht funktionieren
okay noch mal, noch mal, hier, hier da, ja da, da weg, jetzt da hier ich brauche die
escape, escape escape, escape, escape escape, escape, escape let's go, what
was zum
nein
das kann es nicht ernst sein oder
Wie jetzt das geht nicht ich wollte mich für apple das muss funktionieren standard
das kann nicht sein das muss gehen das muss gehen
what the fuck ich stelle einfach auf du ich stelle einfach ipad
das kann doch nicht sein die wollen mir doch nicht wirklich erzählen ich kann das jetzt nicht machen
weil meine capture card die auflösung nicht supportet wie kann man 640 x 480 nicht supporten
640 x 480 was anderes was anderes gibt es das kann doch nicht sein und jetzt was mache ich jetzt
was muss man überhaupt hier drin machen ok ich muss die tastatur ich muss die
tastatur wieder umstecken ich muss die tastatur wieder umstöpseln mal kurz ok
warum ist das bios überhaupt so eine bescheuerte ok also suchen wir mal was muss man hier überhaupt
machen drin also escape drücken serial console ok das interessiert mich nicht in case hier
disable 3 gigabyte memory limit ok ok ok ok man muss das man muss das machen das geht nicht ohne
der chill freak hat eine lösung geschickt zeigt mal her und wenn i switch in obs ok ok in obs
sollen wir das jetzt machen warum muss man sowas über obs machen und kann das nicht einfach hier
drin in der in der in der game capture machen das wird schwach sind schon wieder
hd 60 640 x 480 das muss doch gehen ok dann machen wir es doch über da machen wir es doch
über obs jetzt alles klar also ich hätte ehrlich gesagt nicht gedacht dass das unser
hauptsächliches problem jetzt sein wird das bios vom raspberry pi angezeigt zu bekommen
hier gehen wir mal hier rüber szene weg also machen wir mal machen wir machen sie jetzt
auf mal ich mache sie in der anderen szene leute weil bei eigentlich eigentlich ist egal nee im
zweifel kann ich die szene wechseln guck mal mal et game capture ne nicht game capture was
mache ich dann mit wie ging das noch mal et
aber was muss man noch mal machen damit man das einbinden video capture device
die musik ist aus video capture device
ok und was muss ich jetzt machen da fuck in your configure window profile
be sure you to change this to the fuck
das kann doch nicht euer ernst sein das ich glaube sonnets
ja super jetzt super geil das kann doch nicht das kann doch nicht euer ernst sein
ok moment leute dann könnt ihr halt nicht zugucken ich kann das am anderen monitor machen
ich kann es am anderen monitor machen da könnt ihr halt nicht zugucken
so wie kriegt man das hier jetzt rein
es ist doch mal richtig hängen geblieben es muss doch gehen
es muss doch gehen
alles klar jetzt haben wir fullscreen
jetzt können wir zu dem fullscreen angucken das ist natürlich noch gleich viel besser
ich kann es ja nichts klicken
640 mal 480
und jetzt mag er jetzt
was jetzt
AHA
EXCELLENT
OK, wir machen noch mal DEACTIVATE
GDJZMartin15mona Dankeschön
HUGE SUBSCRIPTION
OK, wie kriegt man eine HD60 x480 Input?
x640 x480
x640
xx
x